[Musique]
ces quatorze finalistes du challenge des
créateurs poste ensemble pour la soirée
des résultats de cette 23e édition 14
finalistes récompensés pour leur
parcours et la création de leur
entreprise
l'assèchement repart ouais vraiment ému
et est plein de motivation pour la suite
encore et je remercie vraiment le
département nous avoir aidés là dessus
c'est vrai que c'était important
c'est important et ça lui et ses chèques
vraiment fruits elles nous permettent
aussi d'investir dans d'autres dans
d'autres choses parce que nous on a
commencé avec un petit budget et
aujourd'hui c'est une vraie récompense
de pouvoir avoir 7000 euros ça va nous
faire du bien
le challenge des créateurs récompense
les chefs d'entreprise partagé dans
cette catégorie la création d'emplois
l'innovation l'insertion la performance
des produits pays
les start up et le prix du jury des
créateurs d'entreprise valorisé par leur
propre insertion professionnelle s'est
montré déjà que sur le territoire
réunionnais il ya des talents
il ya des gens qui aujourd'hui peut-être
n'ont pas d'emplois salariés mais qui
ont des talents pour créer leur activité
créer leur marché et une deuxième un
deuxième point c'est montrer l'exemple
montré que l'on peut s'en sortir qui a
pas de fatalité qu'il n'y a pas de non
plus d'activité fermé et donc tous les
champs du possible sont ouverts pour
ceux qui veulent s'en donner la peine
dans le cadre de l'insertion
professionnelle et avec le département
ils étaient tous demandeurs d'emploi est
aujourd'hui à la tête de leur propre
entreprise ses créateurs sont les
visages de la réunion qui s'est
entreprendre
[Musique]